In the programs that you've seen so far, you've used a single loop to solve a
problem. Sometimes, you need to have more than one loop, and in fact it can
happen that you have one loop sitting inside another. Such loops are called
nested loops. Let me give you an example. We want to write a program that draws
this square of colors starting with the black one, increasing the greenness in
this direction. Increasing the blueness in that direction. How can we draw all
of these squares? Let's think of it a row at a time. For example, to draw this
row here, I need to go from x equals 0 then to x equal whatever the width of
this square is, which is 30 in our example. So the x equals 30, 60, 90 and so
on. And that'll be a loop. That loop will draw on all of the squares in a
particular row. To get to all rows, I need another loop. And there you have it, a
loop inside a loop, nested loops. Now, the only tricky task remains. If I have
row i and column j. How do I find out the position and the color of this square.
You'll get to try that out in the next exercise. Just keep in mind, that as the
row index i goes 0, 1, 2, 3 and so on. You want the y position to be 0, 30, 60,
90, hence on. And as J, the colon index goes from 0 to the number of colon. You
want the x offset also to be 0, 30, 60 and so on. How about the colors. We want
this square down here to have green 255 and blue 255. All the reds are 0. So,
you want the greenness to vary from 0 to 255 in equal increments in this
direction. And you want the blueness to vary from zero to 255 in equal
increments in that direction. You just have to figure out the increments.
Alright, go ahead and give that a try and as you do that closely look at those
two nested loops that you'll be working with.